to build a happy level Consulting
business you can do it that's the path
is already there it's easy to let people
have done it a lot of people actually at
half a million it's enough it's like a
lot of people their ambition actually
really slows down when they hit that
half a million half a million 300 000
half a million it's enough you're not
buying Jets but you can buy like almost
anything you want you're not worried
about the rent and the mortgage and the
first class tickets anywhere like me
whatever A lot of people actually turn
off their ambition in that range and
there's nothing around with that like
maybe that's your work-life balance and
you're super happy and you're cool with
it there's so many ways to win there's
so many ways to win what do you want to
do like what's the most fun to do it's a
heart question not a head question right
what fills your heart to do
hey Evan we got Anka in yep just got off
the plane from Dubai from Dubai all the
way to Canada it's the best place to go
it's the natural place to go I love it
you've come the furthest from anybody
who's doing this with 15 hours I love it
totally worth it cool so I mean what's
on your mind how can I help yeah I want
to start you off with a poem poem wow
because it actually sets the stage
so so it's called Uh chasing you okay
did you write this poem I did nice okay
I've been writing since 1978 and so when
you and I met in 2019 actually
um that's what we talked about we've
talked about my own word which was core
and what you encouraged me to do I was
doing a
uh a keynote shall we say for
booking.com for their Finance group and
you said just that was the first time I
ever put a poem out there for real in
the middle of the way how did it go it
went extraordinarily well okay because I
remember giving the advice but then I
don't remember why yeah you never told
me what happened I'll give you this
advice okay so wow good I'll never
forget and I always come back just so
you know don't give up on me
so this one is called chasing you in the
rush of chasing you I am becoming me the
me that already is already was and will
be and still I keep chasing
I put my ear to the ground and with the
Thunder of the Buffalo and the Deep
vibrating Earth fear for a moment blinds
my heart
puts the cuffs on so to speak
but as the earth needs fire and air and
water I too become the river sort out me
in dismembered air rest in the ebb and
flow of the ocean sister Moon pulling me
into the knowingness of who I already am
and of who we already are
I can yeah I like the Buffalo too we're
in Canada so you got to put the little
Canadian buffalo in there that's great
so yeah so the what's on my mind is that
um there's basically three domains that
constitute in some way of what I want to
bring into the world I'm at a pivot
point I think I've mostly worked for
other folks and other folks as vision
for the past uh X number of decades
um I'm a little older than I look so
it's been decades
and um those three domains are personal
performance so Neuroscience one-on-one
somatic coaching senior executive Focus
so that when I work with them it it
changes whole companies and it's just a
huge amount of Leverage and the second
one is really strategy which is what
I've been doing a lot of for most of my
life so strategy teaming leading that
domain of how together we are more to
create more
how do you engage with your customers
how do you create customer experience
how is there a infinite Loop between
customer engagement customer experience
and what technologies do you bring in
business cases and all that so that
domain and then the third domain is this
one that we started with which is poetry
and Consciousness and raising
Consciousness the shamanic work and at
the center where those two where those
three come together
you know it's probably what I might call
power the power of you the power of your
team and the power of your company
and so as I
since 2019 really have been bringing
that more and more into the world I'm a
facilitator reached at breath work for
example I just got that done because I
want folks to have the ability to do
emotional release and you know you can
go hit a bag or you can go scream but
breath work is actually one of the most
powerful ways to help people
move the needle on some of the emotional
stuff that trips them up so that's a
tool that's it could be a service on its
own but
or uh you know poetry could be a thing
on its own but as you just said it could
also be a tool
yeah I mean if you're if you're talking
to an entrepreneur and even if you
thought you're going to go in and do a
strategy session you may realize oh we
can't even touch strategy because we
have to do a breath breath work session
right right now because the way you are
right now you don't even listen to any
strategy you're going to share anyway so
it's a waste of your time to go so like
people just you have all these tools
that you're using and you're you're
serving an ideal client and you're
serving them the way that is best for
them in that moment yeah
so back to a question about so I'm
serving entrepreneurs and then you said
well then that's not being on stage and
speaking there's a part of me that
absolutely wants to be on stage
um
and yeah but that's I don't know that
that's the path
this is much more of a like you could
there's so many ways to win yeah there's
so many ways to win right what do you
want to do like what's the most fun to
do and this it's like if I can
understand the path that you love the
most and we can design like the weight
over to get there right so what I love
to do is what I just did was I had a 100
so the last time United met was 100
people and I ran I I did a two hour not
a keynote but I ended up making it very
experiential and we did a bunch of
exercises and it changed people's lives
and so I had 100 100 people yeah
but so now you're not coaching uh uh
that's an entrepreneur that's right so
it was a business leader he had a
teaming event that they need to do same
thing that happened just recently one of
my clients needed had a teaming event
and you like doing that or you like
helping the CEOs more
I like
or the equal yeah they're very equal to
me like to be in front of 100 people and
actually change people's lives and just
for two hours have them run through a
bunch of exercises get to know
themselves better get to know their
teammates better work together better as
a team introduce leadership how to be
better leaders it's a hard question not
a head question right like what's what
fills your heart to do often when people
are faced with choices like that where
they're like oh I could do this or I can
do that and I'm doing both one is
because it makes me money and the other
is because I really like doing it so
what I'm most curious about at all to
start with is like what do you love
doing that's hard like if you love
helping CEOs and you love helping team
and they're equal or if you love I
actually like working with 100 people
more than like helping the one person
they're very equal to me I mean when I
think about when I walked off the stage
let's say that walk off the stage and
just people came up to me afterwards
um I love the excitement of it when I
work one-on-one I love the intimacy of
it I love the being able to go deeper I
really like going deep with people and
really profound like what's the river
below the river like what's really
happening like what's really underneath
that and when it's a group I love the
excitement of watching connection happen
yeah
okay as long as it's both equal because
yeah they're both and they're
complementary because you're working
with the the CEO and then you're going
to work with the team yes how big are
the teams typically the people who are
ideal clients for you
so typically the teams end up the team
meetings the teams end up being smaller
like 10 15 people the two exceptions
right now are the 100 people yeah teams
I like the uh I really I'm surprised how
much I really like the big the big stuff
it's a little on the edge for me Comfort
wise but I and I have to get a lot
better at it
um
but
um I don't care what you're comfortable
with yes all right sorry but a room full
yeah and you know then the question
becomes a hundred versus like a thousand
or versus five thousand I've been in
front of 5 000 people and moved them and
when I spoke
they got quiet and they listened in 2000
um
and that
um but that's a very that's a different
that's a different animal like did you
like that animal
five thousand people in the room
I think I like the 100 because it's a
little bit more intimate if I'm really
honest about that okay yeah yeah I think
it's a great great question and what
about helping 100 people versus 10. I
like the buzz of a hundred and I like
the intimacy of of 10. so you like both
yeah we pretend you can go deeper but 10
I can go one-on-one in the middle I
agree I'm just asking I'm not judging no
no no no no I love big groups I love
small groups too yeah just help kind of
you figure out the model so yeah you're
looking at companies that have you know
100 employees or less in working with
the CEO to help level them up as well as
then working with the team and every
program that you do ideally now has both
yeah so you don't do just one-on-one
coaching you do one-on-one plus team
coaching and you don't do just team
coaching you do team coaching plus
coaching the entrepreneur yeah that
makes sense it's only sold as a bundle
yeah for you to get the most out of this
I don't just do one right I gotta help
you and I gotta help your team right
we're going to help you in different
ways we probably could go to companies
that are even larger than like a
thousand employees where then it becomes
a division so like it's a it's the it's
a function like it's the finance
function or is the marketing function or
something like that so you can go to
or it's the customer experience or
customer service function so it could
actually be so it's not just a CEO but
okay so let's play with it in that world
does that still serve your purpose like
you think if you're working with the HR
department of Coca-Cola and there's a
thousand people there and you're helping
or you don't want to do a thousand
there's a hundred people there maybe
it's not good Coca-Cola like Canada or
something HR division you're helping 100
people yeah that would be all right if
it's a business leader does that help
you
does that create enough meaningful
change for you to change consciousness
yeah because it's 100 people and it's a
business leader okay but that business
leader needs to probably my is an SVP or
a c-suite right so it's a it's someone
who has
who went who when they change and shift
and transform
that Cascades
100 a lot of people would say
the ability for a big company to make a
change is Tiny compared to an
entrepreneurial organization who are
like their mission is to change the
world versus a Coca-Cola whose mission
is yeah I don't know
but it doesn't matter for you then it
opens up a much bigger world of who you
can go after yeah
you're limited in how many people you
can take on
yes
personally yes so then the way to
scale that if you care about scheduling
that yeah yeah cool then it's either
like how many people could how many
companies could you take on and do a
great job of at one time
probably six okay it's a fair number
yeah if you're gonna go and host
workshops and go meet people and visit
them and Coach the entrepreneur at any
given time and even then I might I would
probably
at some point I'm going to start needing
some assistance on the systems the
payment the tracking the agenda and all
that so the weather scale is you either
bring on people underneath you and you
have Anka Juniors out there doing your
method yeah and you train them and that
requires you to love mentoring and
training people in your style then like
you end up spending more time training
people than helping companies yeah so
that's a gut check of like do I like
mentoring and training people so now
half my time spent with my team instead
of out in the field so how much do you
value field work versus yeah right
or you how to make
um take equity in the companies
I think the other way to scale is
probably some more automation so both on
the front end and then I think what you
say is very true
kind of there's only so much you can
automate you know when you're yeah
because you got to go and do the work
yeah I I love the work well I feel that
it's great like you're not just gonna
record a PowerPoint and then give it to
the same six clients and like play this
at your event no like you need to be
there you need to be in the room you
need to do the work with them you want
to see the results on their faces and
like the shifts that you're making
because so how do you get how do you get
paid to do that work yeah I mean it's a
great the thing is that's a that you
could take that to a half a million
dollar business or Million Dollar
business yeah cool and maybe that's
enough like enough what's enough I don't
know
um I won't know until I get there right
so if that but that's common like to
build a half million Consulting business
you do it like that's that's the path is
already there it's easy you know people
have done it a lot of people actually at
half a million even in the like 300 to
half a million range
it's enough you know it's like a lot of
people their ambition actually really
slows down when they hit that half a
million half a million 300 000 half a
million it's like it's enough like
you're not you can buy you're not buying
Jets but you can buy like almost
anything that you want you're not
worried about like the rent and the
mortgage and the first class tickets
anywhere like me I just and whatever
right like you're not really worried
about and a lot of people actually turn
off their ambition in that range yeah uh
and there's something around with that
like maybe that's your work-life balance
and you're super happy and you're cool
with it you could push it and as a solo
consultant have a million dollar
business with like one or two outsourced
people doing some work you have a
bookkeeper you haven't you know you have
like some basic stuff you have an
assistant but it's like not a it's not a
team where you're mentoring and training
somebody to do what you want to do
but the scale Beyond a million dollars
as as a solo consultant or like a small
tiny team is
it's really really hard so you need to
figure out if one if that even is what
you want to do and again you may not
know until you get there so you don't
have to Super stress about it but the
models become either I need to scale a
team of mentors of Junior anchors out
there doing their work yeah or I stick
with these guys but I take Equity under
company
and how would you think about so we just
think for a moment we just play that one
I really like that because that's I mean
I just thought that I like which one you
no no taking some Equity stake and I
actually started to think what would
that look like so the question is just
uh to talk through some of how that
might model is that a is that a percent
is that how do you track that like how
does that work how might you negotiate
that
could be anything I mean it depends on
the size of the company so it's like a
20 million dollar company uh startup
technology startup it's not the startup
but it's 20 million but like still start
up there there's in the process of
starting to scale up say right so they
really need that help to go from startup
to scale up they need some some
programmatics in there they need their
what they really need is the way that
they've worked together as a team where
it's just individuals doing their stuff
and just helpers they need to now create
that next model of doing business so
yeah it depends are they well that size
are not a public company but yeah but
bigger companies would be right how much
of an impact can you have right you're
not going to take as big if Coca-Cola is
coming would could you get some shares
maybe but you're not taking five percent
of Coca-Cola to help their HR department
in Toronto right so the Coca-Cola is
probably so let's park those guys for a
second let's take a uh a medium small
size uh small to medium technology
company right there so it depends on the
cap table Yeah have they taken on Equity
or not how much ownership does a person
even have themselves have they ever do
they have a pool for their employees at
all to have ownership in the company or
not yeah mostly the ones that I'm
thinking about actually would have
investors right so they would have
already
investors in there uh right but to like
what extent yeah does the owner have 80
of the company do they have 20 of the
company right big difference and
decisions and how much control they yeah
yeah that's good to think about um and
you may not know and I you know it would
be a question that you have to ask yeah
I don't know how much you dig into like
I do financial side but um
yeah like could you earn one percent of
the company for the next five years and
help them hyper grow
and you get your fee of fifty thousand
dollars a year yeah or whatever a
hundred thousand dollars a year to train
the CEO and that's going to be quarterly
calls or I don't know how often you're
meeting with how often you meet with the
CEO
ever at least every other week so then
it's virtual yeah yeah it's virtual and
we could do and then I'm setting up then
well I need to put in place to set up
which is 2023 is a setup where they can
meet do an intensive for a day a day and
a half like so it's important I think
intensive once a quarter is important
where you just meet in person so
whatever like whatever you need to get
results yeah and you have your package
and this is what we sell yeah and you
guide clients to the package it's not
like they get to pick and choose they
say hey if you want results this is what
you need to do that's super helpful yeah
because they don't know what they need
yes they think they know what they need
they think they like they know it would
be convenient for them but that's not
what they actually need yeah yeah you
know what they need yeah I do so you
have to tell them what they need and
your confidence in the thing makes them
confident in the thing yeah yeah yeah I
remember I I built a boot camp business
outdoor Fitness bootcamp business and I
remember those conversations where like
well if it's not right for you it's not
right for you but I know the end of this
four weeks when you go through this boot
camp this is what will happen for you
like you will be a Chinese person you
will have more power in your life I you
might not lose pounds but I know your
pants will be tighter like looser like
so I I 100 convinced on the results and
I think I have to bring that same so
that's like if you created that kind of
model where you said it's a hundred
thousand dollars a year to work with me
plus one percent of the company
over five years one percent per year as
long as we're getting results you're
happy like we're exponentially growing
your business right so at the end you
end up you have 100K a year plus after
five years or five percent of the
company and you keep helping them build
and grow if that's like a standard model
cool what do I get for that well you get
a bi-weekly meeting with me or every two
weeks a meeting via Zoom you get a
quarterly intensive we're going to come
to your office for
a day two days whatever and work with
you plus you get a twice a year event
where I'm going to do for your team
because not just you we have to help the
team yeah and whatever like whatever I'm
just yeah no no that's right I think
this is but whatever the thing is like
this is what it costs this is what it
costs to get exceptional results
how do you when you when you guide
people to a package like when you think
about guiding people to a package do you
do that by asking questions how do you
or do you say like what does that sort
of
what might that that that sales process
look like
you you have to know what their goals
are like you have to know what do they
care about and once you figure out what
they care about then you then it's just
you tell them what they need to do so I
I mean I get this a lot in the YouTube
world right we're helping a lot of
really big name people
with their YouTube channels and a lot of
it I don't I help my friends but we've
built
five now mid six figure businesses one
pushing seven
coaching you know Jeremy did you meet
Jeremy part of your group so Jeremy now
is an almost seven figure business doing
YouTube Consulting for people wow he
came here it was in your class he was
19. he was working at a grocery store at
the time yeah we're working minimum wage
after the event he's like how can I stay
with you how do I like I'll walk your
dog I'll clean your car I'll mow your
lawn like I just want to be in the same
energy how do I take to it I don't need
to walk my dog you know but I'll thank
you I'll think about it whatever and
then on my tour I thought about him
while we're driving through a desert in
Texas I said Jeremy well I'm going to
start a YouTube Consulting business with
Jeremy and he knew nothing about YouTube
at the time apart from being
so like you watch YouTube videos and I
trained him and how to build YouTube
channels and how he does it for a lot of
big name people
and the biggest thing and now it's now
it's repeated because we did it again
like with three YouTube agencies we have
a publishing company we've got a booking
agency and again the scale the three
four five six hundred thousand dollars a
year is not that it's not that difficult
it sounds like a weird thing to say but
then to see where does your ambition go
after that but it's it's telling your
clients what they need to do because
you know the the people that Jeremy
deals with for example are super
successful business people yeah right
like have sold lots and lots and lots
and lots of of products and services and
have a big ego around what they do and
and how they sell and you need to
complement them on on the stuff that
they're good at so that you can poke at
this one thing which just happens to be
YouTube yeah it's like yeah this like
really sucks
and they're they're actually looking for
people to tell them and you know this
and working with with CEOs they're
looking for somebody to tell them what
to do
and what to fix because nobody everybody
tells them they're doing a great job or
they have employees already telling them
that they suck but nobody's like in a
loving way pushing them forward to say
uncle like you're great and like what
you're doing here sucks like we need to
fix this yeah but not to push you down
but to push you forward and so they the
thing that gives them confidence is your
confidence in the plan yeah that this
thing will work and you're so confident
in the plans like well can we meet every
month instead of no like then you're not
it's not gonna work so my hypothesis my
working apothesis my perspective is that
let's just take a CEO or or one of their
functional heads that they are very good
at taking care of the business but less
good at taking care of themselves and if
they only took care of themselves as
much as they took care of the business
and actually approached that and it's
sort of much more holistic way
um then their their businesses
would go better because I believe in the
power of you the power of your team and
the power of your company and the power
of you is to be how do you get to be the
best version of you fully manifested and
that means I trained with the ex-navy
sales right with Mark Devine and so fed
and so on and so that is that mental
physical emotional spiritual and all of
you like how do you bring all of you so
what if there were a way that you for a
moment had uh some quiet and some rest
and some connection with nature and in
that moment you had space and the
ideation that you're looking for
actually happens outside your brain now
you're in nature and you certainly have
a breakthrough idea so so I would I
wouldn't
um I love that yeah
but I wouldn't also give them tons of
credit yet for saying you're great at
your business
because then what why am I coming in for
strategy yeah
and the truth is
I think this is a different sale
depending if you're talking to the
founder CEO versus a division head
because they have very different
perspectives and viewpoints and missions
and what they want to accomplish yeah
but let's stick to the CEOs entrepreneur
founder
most entrepreneurs if they've built a 20
million company 40 million dollar
company and are in our scaling
um they're Mission driven and want to do
things for a certain reason like I want
to change the world in a certain way
cool
most of them though
on most days
are not living their mission they don't
even remember their mission most of the
time because they're putting out fires
everywhere
and and looking at their financial
reports and figuring out what our sales
cycle is and they're spending most of
their time on things that are not even
connected to the mission they forget
their mission when they're talking to
their team they forget their mission and
they're thinking to themselves about
what they should be doing next so while
they might have had this is where you
can provide tons of value it's like what
you've built is awesome and it's great
and everybody's telling you that you're
so grape it's like you're barely living
your mission yeah you're barely living
great you build a 20 million company
like that's a that's not even indent in
the problem that you're trying to solve
and your problem is you're not spending
enough time actually remembering your
mission and living your mission every
day yeah and to do that we need better
strategy we need you
relax and reflecting in nature writing
poems whatever else need better you need
a better teammate need a better team you
need better leadership like nobody would
call a CEO out on that because the CEO
to to the employees
if I look even I look at my own team my
team is probably thinking Evan is always
thinking about like believe and impact
in the world and having a big mission
because when I like it's when I'm
talking to them I'm talking way more
about that than they are but even me I'm
not thinking about that most of the day
so if you were
to uh engage with a consultant or slash
consultant advisor somebody who can help
you with the strategy can help you with
actually uh accelerating your growth
right it can help you with sort of from
a somatic perspective creating some
breakthroughs
um what are the kinds of things that you
would want to know are hear or find in a
coach uncle
uh it's it's
the feeling
that you know something that I don't
then you can help me get to where I need
to go like when you say somatica what
does that even mean I don't know what
that means body tender but yes but like
but but I get it but the how doesn't
matter like you're gonna have me write
poems or you're gonna have like I
wouldn't even dive into that stuff
because it sounds crazy yes right 100
it's cool right I need to focus on what
are the results that get created by
working together you need to get me to
remember my why and what I'm doing yeah
you need to get me to realize that I'm
still playing small and I don't have the
answers and I need uh like you're like
um the conciliary yes I am the
Consolidated yeah that's what you are
yes so you need to you need to help them
see that every big name person needs to
have a great concilieri like who was
Steve Jobs's concierge he had one I
forget the guy's name yeah uh but like
that's you yeah right you got to find
give examples like Steve Jobs wouldn't
have been Steve Jobs without this person
yeah
and that person helps them stay grounded
helps them keep the most important thing
the most important thing right helps
them and then and then passes that on to
the team so that the it's not always the
CEO's words that are landing but you're
going to come in and actually do the
work as well but you have to help the
CEO feel
like in a loving way forward not that
they're not good enough and then they
suck and they can't do anything but feel
like there's a whole other gear inside
them yeah and you're helping awaken that
inner Buffalo you know to go off and go
go stop and change the world yeah
there's this potential
you have to help them feel that in the
in a session with them before and you
don't have to explain how right or the
mechanics yeah yeah I think I love I
really like the how and I think a lot
about the how I'm a trials adventurers
and I I love the the just keep coming
back to the Y keep coming back to
makes total sense to me yeah but but
like you need to have of course you need
a how yeah you're just going to talk to
them and and hope everything goes great
right no no I can't just give
motivational speeches
but that's the thing that they need to
feel the most is that I'm nowhere close
to my potential everybody tells me that
I'm amazing and yet I still feel like
I'm there's so much more there's so much
more and I don't know where to go to get
the answer yeah Anka might have the
answer for me you know how they very
often say like you you get to a place in
a race or whatever you're going up the
mountain you just want to quit like you
end up at this place where you're like I
cannot go anymore and at that moment
it's true this is maybe still tell you
this all day long because there's
probably 20 40 left in the tank like
this potential that's left inside of us
when we get out of our own way and when
when this this is our conscience that's
dick-jacking at you know saying oh God
what's the difference between Navy how
many like numbers Navy versus Navy Seals
uh there's uh 10x or 10 20 maybe 100
like I have no idea how big the numbers
and Navy Seals you work with Navy Seals
you were in the Navy Seals what did you
do no I wasn't ibco so I worked with
ex-navy seals so I something called
sealfit Academy
and um so you I got very interested in
how Navy Seals do but Navy Seals do like
and so I spent time something called
steel fit Academy and spent time with
those guys okay yeah so whether you want
to use that analogy or not
um it's a great example yeah
to show an entrepreneur so somebody
who's built a 20 million dollar company
it's like you're in the Navy and people
would look to the Navy as like oh my
gosh like you're waking up on time every
day and you're doing the work and you're
like right but you're not an avco that's
like this is nothing yeah I help keep
people from being in the Navy to make
the Navy Seals yeah I think that's
fantastic if you're comfortable saying
that I am totally comfortable saying
I've been I've been wet and Sandy I've
been up at 3am in the morning I've been
so cold I don't know where to go and
I've had my 20x moment in the world like
I had a moment where I thought I had
nothing left and I in that moment I
discovered
the the I'll say just two seconds worth
but we had nothing left in the tank like
zero they asked to do to Burpee so they
were like I couldn't even get one leg
back there and then at some point I said
who's gonna lead this guys this team to
do burpees and I stepped out and there's
10 guys in one Anka
five five o'clock in the morning we're
dead tired I don't know what possessed
me but I stepped out in front of those
guys and they said okay stealth mode is
over
I'm still emotional about it stealth
mode stealth mode is over you will lead
this team with your voice and Inspire
them and I only had to do five burpees
but that seemed like a bridge too far
but in that moment with my voice I said
let's go and we cranked out the purpose
mine were perfect my five were perfect
and all of theirs were perfect and in
that moment I it was 20x and I know this
is possible and so for every single
entrepreneur that I would work with like
there was just like that where you can
go right and it's just unlocking that
and going deep enough and getting you
know getting around some of the stuff
that's that's stopping them in the
unconscious that's unlocking some of the
strategies yeah 100 percent
I mean I've dealt with a lot of these
guys and they're still massively
insecure and if and like have no idea
what to do next I have no idea what to
do next yeah people are looking to them
as like the experts and the gurus and
like they don't know what their next
move is yeah yeah right but this is this
is stuff they don't tell many people so
that's where it's like okay you're
what's the list of the fortune or not
the fortune the the is it the Inc 5000
like the fastest growing companies in
America yeah something like that okay
cool you hit the you hit the Inc 5000.
great you're in the Navy you're better
than most people awesome I want to help
make your Navy SEAL right and you don't
have to write poetry it's okay I do I'll
do that part well maybe you do like it's
a tool who cares like yeah it's a tool
that you use maybe you maybe they need
to they need to get a tattoo maybe they
need to dance naked outside and yell in
the wilderness
I don't like it doesn't matter yeah it
just has to work yeah but the the tools
sound crazy and you don't lead with the
tools you lead with them the only thing
I make them do and I will tell people
about is box breathing like I have to do
a little breathing when they start with
me that's where we usually start this
box breathing cool but it's like don't
explain anything I got that yeah you
just do it before we start here's what
we're gonna do yeah I need you to sit I
need you to sit up straight I need you
to like whatever like and you just it
looks like magic because it is Magic it
is Magic you're creating magic yeah but
the magician doesn't get on stage and
then say okay I had the dove in my
sleeve the whole time guys like this is
how we did it and it doesn't do the
setup okay so no setup you just go off
and do it yeah and it feels like magic
because they're watching you do your
thing yeah and the most important thing
in the sales process is just that they
feel like they could be a Navy SEAL they
feel like they could be the next Steve
Jobs or Elon Musk or the next
entrepreneur of Our Generation to go
solve the mission that they say is on
their website like you say you want to
go up and do this and you're taking like
two percent of the action to actually do
it yeah I love this because one of the
things I believe one of my core beliefs
is very few things are impossible they
may be improbable but they're not
impossible in my my line My my what I
bring is yes you can I bring yes you can
and when they drop in and and and are
just living from their core wanting to
execute on that mission
then
there's so much more becomes possible
it's actually very exciting to me it
makes me it makes me
emotional to think about that
what becomes possible for them so it's
the push like they need to push and they
need the honesty and it's a loving push
it's not a not a judgmental push but you
if you like Evan looked at your website
and you say you want to solve the
world's biggest problem people don't
believe in themselves enough cool
great you have a YouTube channel it's
growing yeah like but what are you doing
dude yeah like what's actually like f
you on your big mission what are you
doing so let's ask that what's in this
moment yeah so so so so let's I know
what I'm doing I'm here talking to you
making this video happen so let's talk
about that for a moment like in if you
say I'm I'm getting to this Mission and
I'm taking action consistently every day
my team is taking action consistently
every day
I'm I'm getting 100 of my mission from
from zero we're not at zero I know that
how close to that hundred percent are
you
one percent
one percent yeah like nothing and if we
were to think about
the two or three levers to pull to to
move that in person to move the needle
on that one percent what would you say I
don't know you have no idea okay like I
come up with something I do it like
YouTube cool we're doing it we're
building we're growing we're testing new
things we're doing these videos will
this work I don't know do we do this
every week maybe do we never do it again
you know okay so tell me more about the
mission
saw the world's biggest problem and what
are the biggest problems people don't
believe themselves
[Music]
what gets in the way of people believing
in themselves
lack of momentum
the wrong people
not feeling like they're anybody who
um
can make a difference usually I'll come
down to like hope which is like the
belief that is possible
community so that you're not doing it
alone and then the how of
well what do I actually do
and to what extent does uh
what's happening in their unconscious
play into that
uh probably a lot I mean I think it
connects to all three of those things uh
what if it's true that what exists in
our unconscious is what's going to drive
us in our actions right so if
my unconscious is sort of this
gatekeeper that says okay if I know it
I'm going to do it if I don't know it
I'm not going to do it
so if believing in myself is something
that I don't know then I'm not going to
do it my unconscious is going to
actually get in my way right if uh at my
unconscious knows not believing in
myself so it's just going to keep doing
more of that how would you help people
with their unconscious
on what's in their unconscious
if I'm doing it one-on-one I have a
conversation and I find something and I
pull it and
I don't have a model or method apart
from listening holding space and then
finding a squishy point and pushing on
that thing okay if I'm doing it at scale
then it's
it's content that helps pull people up
so that they they might go to YouTube
and find a video by me or Tony or
whoever that then shifts something in
their thinking it's by training Creek
community and I don't know how to do
this at scale for community
uh where you now are around like if you
if you pull yourself out of
the environment you're in and plop it
into a Navy sealed environment you're
going to automatically pull yourself up
my best way of doing that is is movement
makers
where if I can train people to go off
and be experts and thought leaders then
they have Ripple effects out around them
but I haven't solved community at scale
I don't know what that looks like I
don't know how to solve it and then
three is that the tactics in the house
like how do you what are you trying to
accomplish do you want to write a book
here's how you write a book you want to
make a YouTube video you should make
YouTube video you want to be a
videographer here's how to be a
videographer so but the first two are
more important than the how because when
you can figure out the hope and the
community the other stuff takes care of
itself
what is that about Community like is
that having a place where people can
have a conversation together like tell
me more about Community I don't know
I mean all I know is that when you are
around
people who are reaching a goal
that you automatically want to become
more like them and when you're around
people who are negative and down you
automatically become more like them and
so if we can raise Consciousness you
know get more people out of their
environments and then be able to put
them back in so they become a beacon of
light my my best way is just again
through Movie Makers or if people watch
the content that they might become
better that then that has Ripple effects
out into their circles and communities
but I don't I haven't figured out
Community scale I have no idea how to do
community at scale I don't know anybody
who's done events are okay
it's a step it's a step but um
it doesn't feel uh it doesn't feel big
enough
yeah so that's really interesting
thinking let's just just to think a
little bit about Community right so
there's this thing called dunbar's
number and so it's it's what is our
where's our cognitive ability how many
folks can I relate to all at once and so
if it's a community a thousand people
like actually can't do that so as a
human being I I need like uh I need a
pod I need like 15 or I need 35 like
there's some place where in that range
somewhere where it's good for me so you
kind of need pods and so one of the ways
that um Tony Robbins does that is you
have your pot of 40 inside of 2 000
people right or you have PODS of 40
inside of 10 000 people but that the
community actually start breaking it
down a little bit and so decomposing
what does community actually mean does
that mean that there is a huge platform
where people can talk to each other you
have some kind of topics where you can
relate to one another because this comes
back to the question about belief
um how how do we get people to believe
in themselves like I come here and have
that conversation with you and how do we
get this out there bigger bigger bigger
bigger
um and how do I you know I I can
certainly tell other hundred people
about it and I tell people about you all
the time right and point them towards
belief all the time but it's just one
more me and so how do we how do we give
me something that then I can give to the
ones that I talk to it's like here
here's a link or here's a like so I
think we want to decompose Community
yeah I mean the church has probably done
the best job at scale yeah
but it's how do you get people who
all I know is if I pull Danny used to be
a delivery guy or FedEx in his life you
know before I picked up a camera I quit
his job however many years ago when he
started doing this right
I don't know how did he get into
videography maybe he met somebody I mean
he started the business with a business
partner at the time when they helped
push each other yeah so part of what
then the community needs to do is uh
matchmaking right
you're interested in something yeah and
so I'm thinking starting to think about
this community thing and rather than
thinking about it as a thing we have to
start to think about the characteristics
of it yeah but at scale so like what's
the model at scale yeah so that makes
sense yeah the closest is a church yeah
which then what did the church do
they created churches everywhere they go
to churches everywhere okay so are we
going to have churches everywhere feels
too slow right
here virtual churches possibly okay what
would that look like I don't know yet
got it
doesn't feel important enough like
if you think about the time you spend
with your family versus like I think it
has to be something physical in the real
world where you're with somebody in that
one person like a big brother or
whatever is helping you become it's
pulling you into a new environment is
taking you out of your home and and
taking you to the gym and teaching you
how to cut hair you're teaching you how
to kickbox you're teaching you how to
use a camera teaching you something
because it that that one interaction
pulls you from your current environment
and shows you a different world yeah so
and I wish starting to sort of get into
some some potential visual of what that
looks like right so if now now if you
had an exchange and I'm just fast
forwarding but you have an exchange
where I can hook up with somebody and
say look I'm really interested in soccer
and I'm really interested in uh yeah so
I'm really interested in soccer and just
the basics now what if I had a place
where I can go look up who knows
something about soccer near me right and
not going to go find somebody to teach
me that particular skill but we have to
infuse all of that with belief like how
do we in that in that process actually
then also bring belief so I have
Community plus belief plus then we're
talking about skills like I want to
learn how to play soccer
read something yeah make have it be an
exchange like I need to feel something
so you have to pick the path that is
going to yield oh my gosh this this I
feel different because I spent time with
akka so then I can dive down that gives
permission to go down to like a
whiteboard session where it's more
guesswork and
messy and trying to figure stuff out
yeah you know on the YouTube world when
I'm helping Jeremy or Drew or Zach or
whoever it's like that classic scenario
is like you're focusing on somebody's
thumbnails it's like but that's only one
little thing like you need to focus you
need to guide them you know I'm thinking
when we're working with clients like I
want to make you the face of blank for
America like the face of whatever like
if you have a YouTube channel because
you want to be known you want to you
want a big impact so you want to be what
you want to be the face of leadership
for America you'll be the face of
Entrepreneurship for America like and
everything is guided towards that you
say how do you convince them like what
are their goals all you're focusing on
is helping them accomplish their goals
which which you can take from their
website especially a mission driven
that's why it's harder when it's like
ahead of HR at some company because it's
a whole mess of what their goals are and
a lot of is political and raising up the
ladder but the founder CEO they care a
lot more about the mission of the
business that they're not living and
it's probably easiest to focus on the
person instead of the strategy yeah
especially if you're coming in you don't
know the strategy yet it's not that you
don't you don't address it but that
becomes
session two yeah
here at TDS right trying to salsa when
people sign up for a salsa class we
don't teach themselves in the first
class
they learn Merengue really Merengue is
Latin dance it's like dance music boom
boom boom boom because the footwork is
just step step step step you don't have
to have
the hardest part to learn sauces your
feet and your hands have to work at the
same time and for guys who have never
danced before it like steam starts
flowing out it's like I need to move my
feet one way and my hands the other way
and I have to think in advance like
that's why they can't dance
so we teach the moringa because you
don't have to worry about the feet at
all all you have to focus on is the
hands and once you get the hands done
it's like oh I can actually get that and
start building confidence the second
class she teaches Bachata which is
harder than meringue but easier than
salsa so even though you're signing up
for a salsa class week one is born gay
week two is Bachata and then week three
to nine is going to be salsa so we start
building confidence along the way
because if we gave them salsa first
class we might lose people after the
first classic that was I can't do this
this isn't for me
so it's like what that in the meringue
class they get the ahas like oh my gosh
I can dance yep this is awesome right
this is crazy I didn't think I could
dance and now I'm actually doing this so
they leave on a high that becomes a job
it's like what is the merengue for you
that when you're working with somebody
that they get an aha moment where I'm
left thinking oh I thought the reason
was this but it's actually this and then
I want to
it's like can we meet next week and like
how do we freaking go over this yeah
yeah right then the path to get to them
is the easiest way is like ultimately
referrals become you get known as the
person who helps CEOs do this thing
right
um but the easiest path through was
through networks like whether it's EO EO
might be a good fit for you or where
were these entrepreneurs hanging out
what masterminds are they going to yeah
that you can be a guest speaker at The
Mastermind yeah and then talk about
something again like whatever is
um going to help them get a result in
the moment yeah that then makes them
want to start to work with you yeah so
instead of going after one person one
person one person at a time who are the
organizations that can introduce you
potentially to 100 or a thousand of
these people at once because you only
need six
yeah six eight yeah or six you know
well it's long term ongoing because
you're taking equity in their company in
an ideal model yeah well they're off the
bridge to that but yes well that becomes
like where are we going right I mean if
you had six people paying 100K a year
that's a great next question even if you
have zero Equity right right and then
that works towards owning piece of the
company right which may mean you fire
half of the clients because they never
want to give you Equity okay you're not
an ideal client for me anymore I don't
want to just earn a paycheck I want to
yeah do something much bigger right
so that's the marketing model the people
who are connected to them the
associations the groups the masterminds
that they're part of you go and you
speak about high performance in those
masterminds yeah and then in the first
session it's figuring out what is what
is the aha moment that you can get
people yeah
yeah to have an unlock so they feel
something and maybe it's actually
physical maybe no I do think the the
moringa equivalent probably is breath
work it's probably well not breath work
I mean just breathing like just drop in
like just drop in where are you like
just you can feel something very
powerfully by just sort of dropping in
and say what does that
with this ideal Vision look like and to
what extent are you far away from that
breath just box breathing will change
everything yeah it's like it could be
anything it just has to work yeah
whether it's meditation whether it's
tapping whether you're gonna put on
touch pressure points whether you're
sound bowling or crystalline or like
whatever they can all work you're going
to be humming we're playing a YouTube
video where I need to make a noise of a
buffalo like whatever the thing is that
then
it could be anything but that's the
thing that they need to feel because
we're we'll make a logical choice to
justify an emotional choice right it's
like we're really making an emotional
choice and we use logic to try to yes
justify it now I know Focus my 2023 yeah
and then well the thing that with that
is that
the the 20 40 million entrepreneur
you know the things that are holding
them back if you're saying is their
mindset is also
for smaller entrepreneurs like you can
practice that you could take people here
yeah and say hey you know what you're in
The Mastermind downstairs right like
yeah I practiced instead of instead of
saying hey you should think about this
like say you know what let's try this
we're gonna do two minutes of breathing
together yep and then walk them through
it and see how they feel so you're
they're all your guinea pigs and they
come in like oh man because I feel so
much better okay I feel more bold and
confident like ready to go off and do I
mean before I got on the on the plane
um from Dubai back here
um I actually did a breastwork uh reset
breast work session with the team there
and it they all it was a small group
it's four people but they all moved the
needle they all had something happen
pretty profoundly
so yeah totally I will tell those guys
downstairs
so so there there are multiple Tools in
your toolkit yes they're all valuable
you're not one of those you're all of
them yeah and you'll add more but
there's eight tools now that you're
gonna add instead of just those three
yep when you're talking to clients and
you your or prospects and you're in the
first session the goal is figuring out
what is the thing in that half hour or
an hour that you're going to create a
magical moment that they feel something
like oh my gosh because it's amazing
even it has nothing to do with their
what they thought you were coming in to
help them with
and then in order to connect with people
that's looking at networks yeah
accountants lawyers masterminds
EO any of those groups or those people
are hanging out so that you can talk to
hundreds at once instead of one at a
time very cool and then number four is
um I would love to talk to Jeremy about
getting the YouTube set up for the
poetry
okay so we got it we'll let you to so
YouTube uh I can introduce you to KIRO
who's the published inside too if you
want to do the book I'm gonna do that I
have one that's 95 done book ready to go
okay it is one of the most gorgeous
Creations ever okay uh I was just first
moment the book opens like this
um beautiful add into the Artistry a guy
in the Netherlands did artists in the
Netherlands and the poems are it's from
2020. it's just these poems are
beautiful and just I'm looking forward
to seeing it yeah this thing I'll
publish through you we'll do it we'll
get it done
was it worth the trip from Dubai I went
it was worth it absolutely thank you
thank you so much all right
to see me coaching another entrepreneur
one-on-one check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe see you there